tensions are boiling over
after India stripped indian-controlled
Kashmir of its near autonomous status
India's decision is reigniting disputes
with Pakistan both control parts of
Kashmir but each country claims the
region in its entirety at worst it's
feared the dispute could drag the two
nuclear powers towards war once again so
as tensions over Kashmir escalate again
what did the parties involved actually
want let's first take a look at India
India says the goal is unifying it's
part of Kashmir with the rest of the
country bringing the territory under
tightest central control could help end
its decades-long separatist insurgency
fighting among the rebels and Indian
security forces deployed there as left
tens of thousands dead Indian Prime
Minister Narendra Modi made gaining
control over the region as central
campaign promised and he intends to
deliver on it but the move is
controversial within India as well some
opposition politicians say it might have
the opposite of its intended effect
rather than bringing Kashmir closer to
India it could further inflame tensions
and lead to fresh violence
[Music]
so what is Pakistan seeking in all this
it wants to see India's decision
reversed Prime Minister Imran Khan says
revoking indian-controlled Kashmir is
autonomy is illegal under international
law in response Pakistan is pressure in
India by moving to cut diplomatic and
trade ties but Pakistan also has a
broader goal for decades it has claimed
all of Kashmir as its own Pakistani
officials have often pointed to
Kashmir's Muslim majority population as
a reason that it should belong to the
Islamic Republic of Pakistan rather than
Hindu majority India and the people in
indian-controlled Kashmir what do they
want
above all most say they would like a
clear say in their own future and many
reject forms of direct Indian rule that
could jeopardize that there's long been
support an Indian controlled Kashmir for
holding a referendum that would let them
vote on the territory's future this has
been promised in the past but never
delivered India's decision affords new
rights to outsiders including owning
property and settling in
indian-administered Kashmir possibly
spelling fundamental demographic changes
for the Muslim majority area in the
future